[Music]
judith is with us in chicago hi judith
how are you
hi good thank you so much for taking my
call i really appreciate it my pleasure
what's up so
my husband and i are in a little
different
of opinion about um oh you're fine
no no we're friendly friendly a friendly
fight it's a marriage [ __ ] it's a fun
yes
so
um if i can give you a little just a
little background of our finances
um currently we have 41 000 in student
loans
um we the house that we still owe like
492
000 on
um
and we we are currently paying
for two cars monthly
that come out to almost like eight
hundred dollars a month gee what do you
own these cars
what do we owe yeah what do you owe on
each car how much money do you owe on
each car
um so we owe for my minivan 22 000
and for my husband's car 6 000.
what's your household income
it's 300 000. okay
all right and 41 022 and six is that the
total of your debt not counting your
house
correct
okay exactly so how quick are you going
to pay off 60 000 bucks making 300
so my husband
says that we can put 3 000 a month
towards the um towards debt and that
that would take approximately
does that make sense two years yeah
that's fairly wimpy
um yeah thirty six thousand out of three
hundred oh you're sacrificing not
you with me true okay seventy thousand
out of thirty three hundred thousand and
you are done in one year
so what are we fighting about again
so we have four kids one with special
needs
um so
we kind of feel like we need i don't
know if we need or it's very helpful to
have two cars because i'm constantly
taking the kid around to appointments
and stuff and my husband needs to get to
work so do we sell
one of these cars no do we
no
no just hold on
you should keep the cars you should sit
down and do a written budget and when
you do get through kicking your own butt
for how much money you're wasting out of
300k
you'll see that you can pay off
everything on this list except your
house in one year
70 from 300k is 230 000 left over minus
taxes call the ambulance i think you
guys can make it
that's the conversation
i'm being mean but i'm trying to point
out to you that if you if you have that
conversation with yourselves
and you go oh my gosh we're playing
around with this we need to get serious
and stay out of restaurants and quit
going on trips and pay off the stinking
minivan i got a special needs kid and no
we're not selling my car i don't know
who it was i want to sell the car but
they just lost this argument
well then i i lost it okay
all right i said we should sell the car
that's awful you got your i kicked your
butt and didn't let you win oh my god
i'm so sorry
what about selling it for a cheaper car
no no no your car's not your problem
your unwillingness to sacrifice the rest
of your lifestyles your problem your
car's not out of line out of a 300 000
budget you're doing just fine you're
gonna get it girl you got it you got
this you need to keep that car you got
those kiddos they're counting on that
car and you that van special needs you
got stuff you need to do there it's not
out of line if you call me up and you
owe a hundred thousand dollars on your
cars and you make a hundred thousand i'm
selling everything in sight and making
fun of you too but not that's not you
darling you guys are in good shape you
can do this